no soy tan optimista para considerar que
el presidente de la república pueda ser
destituido
apegándonos al artículo 130 de la
constitución si bien es cierto de las
bancadas de oposición sobre todo un es
están haciendo las alianzas necesarias
para conseguir los votos creo que esto
no va a suceder se necesitan 92 votos
necesarios de 137 asambleístas y en la
sesión 782 que pudimos ver el día de
ayer nos dimos cuenta que existe una
total polarización política dentro de la
propia asamblea nacional si bien es
cierto la mayoría los asambleístas
críticos la actual gestión del actual
gobierno también se mostraron reacios a
proceder a la destitución del poder
ejecutivo bueno y qué futuro se ve para
solucionar la crisis que vive el país
por las protestas los indígenas han
reiterado que no se van a detener hasta
que se solucionen sus peticiones el
gobierno está en capacidad de
resolverlas
por supuesto que el gobierno está en
capacidad de resolver las deberían tomar
las políticas prácticas necesarias para
solucionar los problemas o por lo menos
empezar a cumplir las promesas de
campaña que dijo hace aproximadamente un
año el día de ayer en la basílica de
quito se intentó organizar una reunión
entre el poder ejecutivo y la conaie sin
embargo en la misma no tuvo éxito a mí
me parece que la jornada legislativa de
ayer que era el punto clave para el
presidente de la república para poder
encargar a sus detractores y poder
manifestar cuáles eran los puntos a
solucionarse en los próximos días sin
embargo como todos conocemos mandó cómo
se va el secretario de la presidencia el
cual no planteó ninguna alternativa para
la solución del problema digamos que en
el contexto que está viviendo ecuador en
este momento realmente serviría de algo
destituir al lazo para que entre otra
figura o puesto sólo crearía más
inestabilidad
y destituir al presidente de la
republica siempre va a generar más
crisis a nivel mundial creo que no
representaría ninguna solución práctica
sin embargo es una realidad que nosotros
no podemos desconocer la situación
política y social al presidente de la
república se le salieron de las manos si
bien es cierto puede ser que no se
aplique la destitución del presidente
según el artículo 130 o la llamada
muerte cruzada según el artículo 148
todavía queda la revocatoria de mandato
popular y los próximos días son claves
porque el consejo nacional electoral
tiene que decidir si va a entregar o no
los formularios para que los grupos
sociales logren recopilar o recolectar
los dos millones de firmas que necesitan
para proceder a la revocatoria